النوم على أرضية المستشفى بعد
قصص الرعب الممرضة المناوبة من ريو دي
جانيرو ، يكون الأمر صعبًا من خلال التغطية 19 ولكن الفقراء
والمكافحين حتى في صورة واحدة
صدمت البرازيل الموتى الذين يرقدون بجوار
العاملين الطبيين في ولاية ريو
الحية يموتون أكثر من أي مكان في البرازيل
30  الأطباء و 40 ممرضًا أو عاملاً
ممرضته دانيال أكوستا يصف
أعراضها في عزلة قبل أيام من
وفاتها ، صديقتها ليبيا ، رئيسة نقابة الممرضات
مصابة بالفيروس
وتخفي مشاكل رئوية دائمة عن أسرتها ،
لكنها أفضل على الرغم من أنها كافية للعودة
إلى العمل  أسوأ ما تقول هو أنه عندما نكون في
حالة من اليأس لمساعدة شخص وصل
حديثًا إلى المنطقة الحمراء ، يتعين علينا التوقف عن
تحضير جثة للمشرحة
وتركها على الجانب عندما توفيت دانييل
، كانت في مستشفى لساعات خارج
المدينة وكانت ليبيا قد عانت من ذلك.  للقتال من أجل الحصول على Kovac
19 على شهادة وفاتها في المرة الأخيرة
التي تحدثنا فيها ، كانت متألقة وتقول إن
حلمها كان أن تعمل مرة أخرى في
خدمة الإسعاف وكان
حلمها يتحقق.  لساعات
للتقدم لهذه الوظائف ، عانقتني على الرغم من أننا
لم نعد قادرين على العناق في ذلك الوقت ، كانت
سعيدة لأنها ستستخدم الزي الرسمي مرة أخرى ،
كان حلمها هو النقص في PP على
الرغم من
أننا في وحدة العناية المركزة في المستشفى قيل لنا إنه بخير
عدد الموتى في ريو يفهمه القلب
على الرغم من أن البعض يقول إنه لا يتم الإبلاغ عنهم
في هذه المستشفيات التي أراها تستخدم هناك 88
أربعة أسرة وحوالي ستة إلى ثمانية
مرضى يموتون كل يوم أي حوالي 10 ٪
من مرضى وحدة العناية المركزة يوميًا تخرج الحاويات
للخلف  مع مساحة تتسع لـ 75 جثة في وقت
وصلت فيه الذروة إلى ريو الآن ، يعتقد بعض الخبراء
أن موظفي الرعاية الصحية مرهقون بالفعل في
الصباح والمثقل كاهل نيك
باتون والش سي إن إن ريو دي جانيرو البرازيل